and so knowing that subscribers is is a
nice thing to have but realizing that if
that's your only motivator like you're
going to come up short you got to have a
bigger why you got to realize i'm here
because i have a message i have a
mission i have a greater purpose with
what i want to accomplish
so you may be trying to grow your
youtube channel this year and your goal
might be to actually get to 100 000
subscribers my name is heather torres
and i am the host of the think media
podcast and today i'm so excited because
i have my friend and fellow vra member
justin
oh man i was gonna say co and you
corrected yourself no you got it right
hey we're keeping it in there and vra
member justin coo with me on the podcast
today we're gonna be breaking down his
seven tips from going from zero to over
100 000 subscribers on his youtube
channel but justin for the audience
who's just getting to know you uh tell
us a little bit about who you are and
what your channel is about sure my name
is justin kuh i'm a husband and a new
father and on my channel i host explicit
conversations on belief and the stories
that shape them and so in essence my
show
is kind of an across the aisle type of
show where i oftentimes expose myself to
people with a different life story a
different set of beliefs and and really
for the purpose not of debate but to
understand and to empathize and to build
relationships uh the show's called i'm
listening and a good chunk of the show
i'm just
sitting there listening to what they
have to say i also love listening to
your content i'm listening as you are
going into these uh deep conversations
and really just hitting different taboos
um and things like that so so appreciate
the work that you're doing but
this has been a journey right it's not
like you just came on youtube yesterday
and got to over a hundred thousand
subscribers so talk to me a little bit
about the journey how did you start and
then we're gonna dig into your seven
tips yeah so it must have been five or
six years ago i started youtube i was
teaching at a school at a bible college
actually and one of the students who
came through shared his story of faith
which was it was because of a youtube
video that he had this life-changing
moment and it was it was kind of in that
moment i'm like oh my goodness like
video is powerful it has the potential
to reach people not on a surface level
it's not just about cat videos or social
experiments but like it can change a
person's life in a significant way and i
thought that's brilliant i want to try
and be a part of that
i remember googling for youtube courses
and i stumbled across the beta
vra like this was before it was polished
i don't even think you guys were in
kajabi at the time it was just like
things were falling apart the roof was
leaking all this is like literally one
of the emails i'm like hey guys can you
guys go and click all the buttons and
tell us if something's broken and i did
that and i'm like yeah that one's broken
and that one's broken yes um but i found
you guys and found a community and and
this was kind of me diving in head first
and and as they say the rest is history
i think 10 months later i ended up
quitting my job as a faith move not
because i was making millions and
millions of dollars yeah but i was like
i'm so i'm so convinced that this
matters and i want to be a part of this
and so i launched in headfirst and and
we've been doing it full time ever since
yeah and you know i think one of the
things we're going to dive into the
seven tips but you know 100 000
subscribers is such this
this youtube milestone right i mean it's
cool like you do get cool plaques and it
is a recognition i got mine uh i think
last year maybe a year before yeah
but man there's such a journey along
that way so i want to dive into these
seven tips um and number one was
actually that a hundred thousand
subscribers doesn't matter yeah and you
might have clicked on the video because
like oh i wanna get 100 000 subscribers
and i remember what that was like i
remember having goals and wanting to hit
these milestones and that's cool if it
helps motivate you it helps get you out
of bed helps you to hit record every
once in a while like good use that that
fuel use that energy but at the end of
the day one of the things that i'm more
convinced now than ever is that these
are just vanity numbers like and and
they don't really accomplish much it
might have been true that you know 10
years ago the old youtube subscribers
mattered because whenever you would
create a video it would be sent to all
of your subscribers but now that's just
not the case you don't need subscribers
to be able to reach people and in fact
there's oftentimes channels that have
less subscribers but they have larger
reach and so i think it's just important
to be able to have your eye on the right
target because if you have the right the
wrong aim even if you're successful
you're still missing and so knowing that
subscribers is is a nice thing to have
but realizing that if that's your only
motivator like you're going to come up
short you've got to have a bigger why
you've got to realize i'm here because i
have a message i have a mission i have a
greater purpose with what i want to
accomplish
i want to jump up and down right now it
makes me so excited um and not for like
a braggadocious way but we hit a million
subscribers
and the next day we got up and we've the
same day
it's almost like when you have a big
milestone birthday 100 and i i that's
how i love to help people understand it
it's like man if you hit you know maybe
you turn 30 or 40 or 50 or 60 and you
think something's gonna happen and you
wake up the next day and gotta do the
same routine and the whole thing well i
i remember getting my silver play button
in in the in the mail and i'm like i've
been working for this day for so many
years it was a really cool moment i
called one of my buddies i was like hey
would you mind helping get a bunch of
photos for instagram and like there was
this moment where i i indulged my vanity
i indulged the hard work and all of that
i took the photo and now it's under my
bed like it's in the box it's not even
on my wall it's like this thing that
just like i use sometimes as a makeshift
tripod like it's it just it doesn't
matter as much as i thought it would
matter yeah because you said it it's
building something bigger beyond just
youtube and that's what we want you to
know here on the think media podcast why
i want to have these conversations is
because yes i get it like i want to get
as many play buttons as i can because it
means i'm reaching people right and even
today um in our uh in our calls that we
have as a team um we do customer success
every single call because there's so
many success stories that are big and
small right it's not just about the
numbers and we had a customer success
story today of of a woman who started
her youtube channel in attraction
marketing i mean talk about like let's
be like super narrow on what she's doing
she's like 400 subscribers but she sent
us a testimony that said because i built
a business around what i'm doing and i'm
using youtube to get leads and get
clients and get people into my world
she's making ten thousand dollars a
month with 400 subscribers so it's the
equivalent of subscribers to income
actually isn't a big deal what matters
most to youtube is
minutes matter most they want people on
the platform they want people diving in
which is why i love the content you're
doing now and i love the content you
were doing before but now it's long form
it's keeping the mirror it's people are
digging in and it becomes something more
than just um than just you know cat
videos like you said and number two
actually is that uh consistency
matter so actually getting to these
vanity numbers is a good thing but
really what matters is staying
consistent why is that a thing for you
and for creators who are just starting
and just need to know that while it can
be difficult to get a video out every
single week for the last six years you
know or whatever that was um it matters
yeah well consistency matters so much
because it's it's just the only
dependable strategy you can rely on i
mean you think about it in like
financial competency right yes you could
win the lottery and that is a path to
success but like i don't think you're
wise to bet on winning the lottery if
you're trying to be financially secure
it happens it's a real thing clearly it
does but like it's not repeatable in the
same way you know getting a viral video
might actually happen and i i hope it
does for you because that's great it
just accelerates your growth but the
reality is is that for most of us we we
don't have viral videos right um and so
that's why consisting man consistency
matters the most but but also it matters
because it actually helps teach you how
to grow and how to develop it's like
riding a bike you could read a book on
riding a bike and like you can fill your
head with all the knowledge but until
you get on a bike and fall down 100
times you're never going to learn how to
ride a bike and so the you know the
advice that i'm giving people is like
you have to be willing to make 100
pieces of content that each get less
than 100 views like if you're not
willing to do that then you really
haven't paid the price that's that you
need to pay in order to be successful in
whatever way that you want to be
successful yeah i equate it to uh man it
sounds like oh yeah okay heather
consistency matters you guys say that
all the time you know and and but it
does yeah and and right now i'm in this
huge project i'm writing a book it's
going to come out next year and man when
we talk about uh you know what could
these book sales be and this is just
just an example but like what could
these book sales be we've got this
number obviously we're like yeah it'd be
great to hit that number but actually
what we're focused on are what are the
outputs we can do what are the things we
can commit ourselves to like what kind
of outputs are you like how many shows
can i go on how many youtube videos can
i make about it how many instagram posts
can i do what is the output that i'm
gonna commit myself to to be able to
even just get that out there and i think
as youtubers in in any other sense if
you were to go and open a coffee shop
it's not like you're like well i think
i'm only going to open my doors maybe
three days a week right you want to be
open as much as you can and so the more
videos you can do the more consistent
you can be the more opportunities you
have to reach the people you want to
reach and the more you actually define
your message if you make two youtube
videos and you're like no one's watching
yeah and then we watch it and we're like
because you don't have a consistent
message consistency of the messaging is
what helps people trust you over time
this is we we understand this in every
other area of life the more seed that
you sow the more likely you're gonna
have a harvest that's just the way that
the world works yeah yeah so i love that
so you learned uh subscribers don't
matter in that respect 100 getting to
100k is great but
there's more beyond 100k um consistently
matters next one actually is to focus on
going deeper
rather than wider talk about that a
little bit yeah so in my context this is
something that i've seen happen in kind
of the other type of work space that i
work in i i work with a lot of churches
and one of the questions that a lot of
churches are are thinking about is like
how do we grow our church larger how do
we serve more people how are we able to
spread a message that we believe in you
know to more people and that's great but
one passer gave me advice
said
instead of looking over the person's
shoulder
looking for the next person to walk
through the doors what if you just
looked at the person who's in front of
you and loved on them and served them
well and it's just this idea of like
listen if you're always looking for the
next person then there's a there's a
certain sense when people show up they
realize like oh you weren't actually
here for me you're here for someone else
you're here for a vanity metric you're
here for a number so if we're able to
shift our focus away from focusing on
all these other flashy colorful things
but instead we're focusing on hey you're
the one person who's watching the video
today how do i interact with you well
how do i actually serve you well what
are the problems and challenges that
you're facing and if i can dive deep
into my community that's that's a way to
build trust that's a way to to make uh
to to build influence and and kind of a
tandem strategy with this is that as you
go deeper in this way you're by
definition creating your niche you're
discovering your niche a little bit more
which as as everyone who's watched any
of your guys videos you know that that's
the step number one you have to have a
clearly defined niche well going deep is
the way that you discover and serve your
niche better yeah and we have seen that
over and over and over again is that
when you just try and cast this wide net
man people just want your help people
want to be people want to be in
community with you they want they want
what you have to offer so when you do
keep just looking for the next thing
they feel so undervalued and it actually
goes into the next point which is number
four when you go deeper rather than
wider you can actually have options to
diversify your income because people
have a problem and multiple problems
usually where you can then help and
serve them so talk about number four
which is in building 200 000 that you
should be focused not on the number of
that but on diversifying the income
streams into that thing yeah so one of
the things that i thought that i would
have as my path to success when it comes
to financial success on youtube was okay
if i hit 100 000 subscribers well that
means i'm going to be doing x number of
views every single month which multiply
the ad revenue okay then then i can
start to see the numbers adding up well
clearly we know that that's just not the
case for most of our smaller or
medium-sized channels like ad revenue is
not going to be significant enough so we
we learned strategies through vra like
you know affiliate links and
sponsorships and things like that and
that all works in in a lot of niches but
it felt unnatural to my niche yeah if
i'm if i'm talking about faith you know
no one loves the televangelist who
passes the the collection bucket like
and i didn't want to be that person so i
felt like my hands were tied how do i
actually turn this into something
sustainable yeah well what i realized is
by hitting record like a hundred times a
year or more than a hundred times a year
is that i was developing a skill and
sometimes that skill was in the process
of like hey hosting an interview like
hosting a podcast became a skill of mine
so what did it look like to shop out
that skills to say hey there's an
organization that i value that i trust
that i want to work with and i say hey i
got the skill set i can deliver you a 50
episode podcast for this amount of money
you do no work that turned out to be to
be an actual income revenue stream or
realizing that hey the process of
filming a video i learned and developed
a a an art form a skill set around
making videos yeah so what does that
look like to turn that into creating my
first you know 10-part documentary
series and selling that as a service and
then you know for every thumbnail that
i'm creating i'm doing multiple
photographs and start to turn that into
a revenue stream so what i learned was
that youtube was kind of like school
yeah and no one expects to go to school
and make money you go to school to learn
and once you develop these skills and
you're able to employ them in the world
and what turns out is like that's
actually a way more fun way to do things
because if youtube died tomorrow and all
my money's in ad revenue and
sponsorships that are distributed
through my youtube channel that has a
hundred thousand subscribers but youtube
dies tomorrow like there goes all my
money yeah but if i know how i can
because i've faced rejection a hundred
times because i've had videos that
flopped a hundred times like i know what
it's like to go and knock on doors at
local businesses and say hey i got the
skill set i noticed that you local dog
shop you know you don't have a podcast
yet i would love to be able to do that
for you what would it look like so for
for me to be able to serve you well i've
done that and i've been able to turn
that into revenue and so it's actually a
really cool way that i can do what i do
on youtube from a purely passion
perspective i do it because i love it
because i believe in it and the rest of
the stuff happens in the background and
it kind of it all works out because of
the skills that i've learned on youtube
man oh we're going to dive deeper i want
to do a bonus episode just for the
ministry community or the faith-based
community because we have a lot of
people that are in the think media
community who want to do what you're
doing and can't see that path and really
want to figure out how to how to connect
those dots so i want to do a separate
episode just on that part of it um but i
want to go into number five which is
don't be afraid to try new things maybe
walk us through just a little snapshot
of the journey of the now justin
channel but it was that christian
vlogger channel you even switch full
brandings the whole thing so like don't
be afraid to try new things um how do
you see that as being helpful to get to
that hundred thousand i i think it's
helpful in a number of number of reasons
because it one it helps you just
discover your voice a little bit more
trying different formats and different
approaches does give you a different
lens with which to view how do you want
to deliver and serve your community i
think it also helps because it's fresh
it gives your your die hard community
kind of like a breath of fresh air if
you're always doing the same thing and
showing up in the same way it can get
tiring a little bit so what that looked
like in my in my context when i first
started that christian vlogger was the
name of the channel it was me vlogging
and what i found was like this is a
really time if anyone's ever tried a
daily or just even weekly vlog you know
how much work it is and i was just dying
like and so i started to do like talking
head videos and i realized oh i could
turn out one a week very easily and
that's super fun so i did that for a
season and then i started to see that
you know youtube had just really like
leaned in algorithm wise sort of like
the live content yeah so i started doing
a daily live stream and i realized like
i'm able to go really deep with like a
small percentage of my audience and that
was a fun learning experience
so i've gone from you know the vlogging
experience to the monologues
to doing live streams i've and i've
probably done at least 100 episodes of
each of these styles of content yeah and
now i'm doing like more of the long form
podcast style and so what happens is
like i have a well-rounded skill set so
now when tick-tock is blowing up and i
just like as you know we've been talking
in the car i just started my tick tock
like two weeks ago what took me a whole
year to get to 10 000 subscribers on
youtube and i thought i was on the fast
track
what i've been able to do is i've tried
so many different formats that when a
new uh medium shows up i'm it's very
easy to be like oh
well i can pivot really fast and now i'm
turning out content really quick i've
hit 10 000 subscribers in in two weeks
yes and so it's just you develop the
skill set you're able to become much
more well-rounded and you know back to
the monetization thing you're able to
sell that skill set in multiple
different areas and help many different
types of clients yeah and not being
afraid to even switch your entire brand
like people don't even want to get
started justin because they're like i
don't know what my name should be i'm
like pick
a name because you can change it it's
okay um you can develop a second brand
there's so many things you can do we
even did it here on this podcast we
started it we
molded around for two years and then we
were like we need to just start this
thing because if we don't start it now
we're not going to start it so we
started it it was called the think
marketing show now it's just the think
media podcast and now we have all these
other shows that we're going to be
creating under that umbrella but it took
us doing over a hundred episodes maybe
maybe 50 episodes before we were like
you know what this isn't actually the
direction we want to go let's pivot
let's do these things and it just when
you get to try new things
it doesn't have to be forever it could
be for a season it could be three videos
it could be that maybe you just went
live
two times to just try it uh people like
fresh and new and so how can you bring
that to your audience to make it fun
i mean if you look through my library of
content you'll see probably at least a
dozen like
first episodes of a series that never
made it past a first episode yeah and i
like and you go to the call to action
like in my next one i'm going to be
talking about this and it just never
happens because you realize in the
process
maybe that's just not what i want to
show up as that's not what i want to
give or maybe it just didn't work and
it's okay to try those things it's okay
to to throw a hail mary every once in a
while and see what happens yeah and
people
listen to me please start pick a
platform pick it pick a strategy and
just get started because you're gonna
change it a hundred times throughout the
whole thing but if you don't even just
pick something you won't even start and
so just let it go justin said right now
you need to try new things it's okay uh
all right number six i'm just looking at
my phone here number six is invest into
what you were trying to grow in and you
gave a little bit of the story that you
know uh you had jumped into video
ranking academy it's not like you were
making millions of dollars when you
decided to join video ranking academy
and that's just one part of education
you invested in the gear and you
invested in leveling yourself up with
learning other things learning how to
edit learning you know different uh
learning how to market learning how to
start a business all of these pieces but
why is it so important that if you're
within that zero to 100
000 subscribers that you turn internal
and put your money in yourself put your
money into what you want to become yeah
for me one of the things that i valued
is trying to understand why why is
something not working why is something
working i think even maybe a scarier
place than having little subscribers and
little viewers
is having a viral success having a
million subscribers and not knowing why
not knowing what worked how did this
reach people what are people coming back
for and then you just got this massive
amount of anxiety this imposter syndrome
that shows up like so so for me one of
the things i'm wanting to do is with
whether a video hits or it's a miss
whether it's a success or a failure i
want to learn from it i want to
understand what's going on and sometimes
that happens to like a course like
you're talking about sometimes that's
through the youtube secrets books
sometimes that's through getting
personal one-on-one coaching or whatever
the case is name all of the things we
give yeah affiliate links in the
description below yeah yeah
but but just being able to understand
why like that like if part of what i'm
offering as a service is is offering
creative skills to other people i need
to be able to just say not only hey have
i done the work have i grown a channel
but i can actually understand and give
you an intelligent reason as to why
things are working so when i give you
advice
it lands better like there's a there's a
there's a reason behind it um investing
yourself is is so important if youtube
again if youtube was to go could put and
now we have this new platform that where
all the attention is like if you don't
know why you're growing on youtube if
you don't know the principles behind it
like you're not going to be able to
successfully transition and so investing
in yourself more than you're investing
in anything else like that's that's just
the only way to be able to be successful
yeah and for me it was things like um
buying online courses buying the books
not even that going to the library but
it also was going to conferences it was
getting around people investing taking
the leap of saying like no i i do want
to do this i want to get around other
people that are doing this and that
could be virtually or that could be in
person and i think that was such a huge
thing you came to growth video live one
got around people and you found other
people even in the space that you're in
that you could just kind of bounce ideas
off of and and feel like you're a part
of that community well and that i mean
that was super valuable in addition to
that one of the other things that i
would do is i would find people that are
in my niche but who are states away and
i would prioritize
saving money to buy a plane ticket to
fly out there spend a weekend with
people yes to do the collaborating to be
able to try and grow each other's
channels but also the conversations
around dinner like those are huge like
what is working what is not working what
are we trying to accomplish as a like
you know a general community like
those are learning experiences and
prioritizing and that helps you build a
network helps you have other people to
rely on and it just it makes everything
better oh so good we're going to get
into um the last one but if you're
getting value out of this and you're
watching on youtube right now hit the
subscribe button if you want to hear
more conversations like this and
actually let me know so far what's been
your biggest aha and i think really
we're going deep into beyond just like
get views get subscribers this is
building something of purpose that
matters that's helping people and you're
so knowledgeable justin in just how
you've been able to you know not not
necessarily know the path forward but
just start walking in and start going in
it so let me know in the comments if
you're listening on the podcast right
now i'd love for you right now to take a
screenshot
screenshot go over to your instagram
upload that on stories and tag us both
because i want to know uh if you're
loving this um one and i'll put our our
uh what are those called handles i'll
put our handles down in the description
um of both youtube and over on the
podcast but uh tag us let us know that
you're listening all right number seven
is build a team
more creators need to hear this because
your creators that are at the top of the
mountain are not doing this alone and if
they are they are probably on the verge
of burnout or they're doing it paycheck
to page i mean they're literally on just
the brink of not being able to do it so
building a team especially as you're
moving into new seasons of life and
moving into creating this business
around it what is that done for you in
the 100 000 and did you build a team
before 100 or was it after 100 i i
wanted
the team that we have now is a team
that's been assembled after a hundred
thousand okay but the impact of it is is
dramatic whereas i would spend i don't
know 20 hours a week editing my own
content now i spend almost no hours a
week you know like i'm i get to do the
part of this of content creation that i
love that i feel like is uniquely me and
then i get to rely on people who are
much better at all the other things than
i am whether that's the story editing
that's the actual physical editing of it
or the you know like i get to depend on
the expertise of other people and that's
been tremendous i think one of the other
things that it allows me to do is it
actually gives me an in to participate
in other creative people's projects so
one of the biggest objections that i
would have had hearing this kind of
advice of building the teams like okay
yeah if you have money of course build a
team but like i didn't have money when i
was building a team what i did have is i
had other creatives in my in my niche in
my network who were also in the starving
artists kind of a face
and you know what i could bring to the
table because they like say i have a
friend who's who's a writer he writes a
blog does a fantastic job with writing
but doesn't doesn't even own a camera
much less know how to work it and take
good photos or videos or anything else
like that what does it look like for me
to serve and to volunteer for an entire
day help him record a month's worth of
content
for no cost and then in response like i
spend that one day with him he then
turns around and spends an entire day
editing a lot of my stories and and
crafting the the the story arc that i
want to be able to present we can just
do it in exchange for services and what
happens is his work is elevated and my
work is elevated and we've developed
this natural relationship with each
other so that when a paying client shows
up which is this is actually kind of how
it's been happening yeah that there's a
client who says hey
friend over here who does all the great
writing we want to hire you with this
budget to do this this and this is
marketing campaign this writing campaign
whatever the case is we would love for
you to participate he's like oh perfect
i'll do it and i know just the guy to
partner with
and vice versa if someone says hey we
want you to do a documentary i'm like
hey i don't want to edit that
i don't want to have to even write that
i want to be able to sit down and film
it and do the parts that i love to do so
i'm going to bring him on and so what
we're leaning into is this concept of
like the rising tide lifts all ships
yeah and if you're able to serve someone
else who has a weakness that you have a
strength and vice versa you're going to
be able to go so much further and so
much faster and beyond that like
sacrificing your own money to do it i i
would think about it this way it's like
okay if i'm editing my own video and i'm
taking 20 hours to do it even if i'm
making minimum wage there's a cost there
there's an opportunity cost what does it
look like for me to actually pay someone
out of my own pocket but then be able to
redeem that time to be used in building
the business in another aspect could i
redeem that time and actually maybe land
another business deal land another
project where i'm actually net winning
where i'm able to pay someone so that
they can take care of their family and i
have more income because i'm not doing
it by myself anymore yeah yeah and i
there's a couple things you said i want
people to really take away from one the
self-sacrifice you know again and we
can't say this enough it's not like
people that are building teams are
making millions of dollars they're
basically making enough that they can
then
sacrifice a little so they can gain more
on the back end and the other thing that
you said when you're in the car when i
asked you about your editor um you're
paying someone three times their living
wage and so you're you're sometimes five
times sometimes five times uh someone's
living wage and he's an amazing editor
you wouldn't even know look at his look
at his content he's an amazing editor
and even for us here at think you know
now we are 18 strong full-time with
salaries and you know we're doing we're
doing like we're a company now we are
legit like making it all happen hr
there's policies you know the whole
thing um and that was not where we
started we started with hey omar can you
for some tacos come and help us film
this tacos are always a win
with tacos and omar was so skilled in
what he did that he made the process go
faster and when you hire a team you now
are doing something beyond yourself well
but i mean even rewind the tape a little
bit further back this is what happened
between you and sean yeah yeah you guys
started for free helping each other out
with skill sets and you just elevated
each other yeah and it's because of that
sacrifice you were willing to put in i'm
guessing dozens if not hundreds of hours
three months
yeah three months of full-time free work
you know and um yeah and that's exactly
it we we both had skill sets that we
brought to the table and because of that
i've now developed the skill to be able
to do this i was not this girl no when
we started no i remember you remember i
was the girl that was like behind the
keyboard you know um and i've been able
to develop to this but
the other part when you start hiring a
team is you got to get your video into
them
it makes consistency happen then you're
like well how can your brain starts to
go to well how can i make more revenue
and then you start to diversify like
building that first team member i think
is so critical if you're building a
channel because it makes you start to
think beyond this could be a thing to oh
this has to be a thing now i got to
figure this out and when you start to
shift into that mindset opportunity
comes collaborations come there's so
much more that happens in abundance for
that channel than if you were to just do
it by yourself it also unlocks the door
towards longevity yeah because if you're
like any other average human you're
spending 10 20 hours editing your own
content and i think about the community
that i serve pastors who are wanting to
step into the digital space they've
already got work they've got to do
visitations they've got to do sermon
riding they got to do all you know
sitting on the board to the church and
whatever else that they're doing if
they're adding another 20 hours into
their their workload to edit a video
like they're burnt out very quickly
so just
giving that work to someone else and
actually being able to buy back your own
time to be a husband to be a to be a
wife like that might just be more worth
it yeah definitely well justin i so
appreciate you
i cannot believe it's been six years we
are heading into we've just begun yeah
isn't it crazy i mean we're where we are
today but we're just beginning i'm so
grateful that you invested in us that we
got to become not just you know some
mentors in your life is it weird to say
that
i tell people because because you know
people send me screenshots of like my
face yeah and shawn's slide talking
about vra or whatever the case is like
i'm like oh yeah he's my buddy he's my
coach he's like he's my mentor yeah
you're like oh wow that's amazing that
you even know him like
yeah yeah no that's exactly how i see
you guys yeah it feels weird for me to
say that because i feel like we're just
on this journey together like i feel
like i learned so much from you just as
much as you're learning from us but i'm
so grateful that you're part of our
community that you're helping people in
this way um and just be getting so so
excited where can people go if they want
to see more about the content you're
creating and they want to get connected
to you uh everything is tied to my name
justin coo k-h-o-e so
the website's justin cute.com my youtube
channel is justin kuh instagram is jaeku
which unfortunately looks a lot in text
at jk ho
but it is jake
yeah uh and on tick tock it is justin go
follow him on tick tock i was watching
your tic talks today and i was like i
need to get on this i need to start
doing well you're saying that because
the last two tick tocks were filmed
outside of your house that's true that's
very true and so every week we love to
read your comments that you're leaving
over on apple and today's comment of the
day comes from jeff
a811 he says love it
loved the latest episode why youtube
creators get stuck and stop growing your
channel podcast isn't the first i found
for helping and growing my influence and
impact online but it's the one i listen
to most regularly because i think it's
the most real and helpful thank you
explanation point also just listened to
the book youtube secrets because i just
couldn't get enough the book was awesome
as well thanks for all the help tips
advice and real talk to help my channel
get off the ground jeff from doze of
dose of dirt jeff thank you so much for
that amazing content that is what we try
and do here we want to go deeper in the
conversations that creators just like
you want to know about we're we have
upcoming episodes about brand deals
about confidence about how to actually
scale a team how do you do it and so
we're going to be going deeper into
those conversations but i want to thank
you for being a part of our community
here at the think media podcast make
sure you subscribe to this podcast
wherever you listen to it from and we'll
catch you on the next episode bye are
you ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
you